you billy d williams jason
schwartzman alice and jenny that's great
dicknannigans all right
[Music]
six-time emmy award winner alison jady
will light up your tv screens later this
week in a brand new mini-series what
happens when a frontier woman ride in
the trail learns her father is an apache
chief
that's wagons a nine part mini-series
coming up later this week on ccn family
i know i'm going to be watching that one
oh yeah
trick the light fantastic when west wing
star alison janney makes her debut on
star dancing on ccn don't miss allison
as she tangles her way into your heart
that's next week on ccn check your local
list alice and janie who stars in a
haunting on 4th street a supernatural
thriller you won't want to miss allison
johnny plays a woman who is possessed by
a demon that is also possessed by a
different neighbor
that's a double up viewer discretion is
advised coming soon alison janney stars
as fran a woman who means to visit her
nephew for thanksgiving but she drives
to a small town she's never been to
while in a trance
ten years ago in the same town kathy who
looked just like fran was murdered
the town assumed that kathy's boyfriend
arthur who went missing at the same time
as the murder had done it but fran
starts having multiple dream sequences
and trances that reveal that something
else
was up
gradually through investigation and with
the guidance of war vision fran uncovers
the story behind the murders and that
she was in fact
the murderer
was that all on the prompter yeah the
whole twist ending and everything ready
i mean why watch the show all right
let's just hear it
tonight
alice and janie is a former actress who
was made queen mother of all things when
the computer graphic known as enos
ascended to a state of self-awareness
the digital deity queen jani now
presides over the cyber realm while her
mechanical minions heard and control the
last remnants of the plague that was
once
humankind that's tonight and for the
rest of time
this has been today's mandatory message
oh hell queen alex and jenny
you sold me out son
now you're gonna end up with a bullet in
your head for it
you can't play mean
[Music]
nigel that's great oh great it's
smashing thank you so much yeah tom well
it's been an absolute honor and and what
a great opportunity to be here and be
able to play an american tough wow i'm
just so glad that we got you out of that
bbc commitment so you can play with us
cheers mate cheers
antoine listen i'm just not buying that
you're someone that was born and raised
in the streets of brooklyn
that's weird cause i actually was born
and raised on the streets of brooklyn
i was in the gang and everything most of
this stuff
actually happened to me wow okay well
that's that's that's great for us
because i want you to use it okay it's
good first take let's just uh let's get
going let's go let's get going thank you
jim
scene five take two
and action
you sold me out son
now you're gonna end up with a bullet in
your head for me
you can't play me brother
i'm the mother
that plays mother
mother
cut
cut
okay uh nigel that was great oh
brilliant just the way you move
especially when you talk i just really
see this character coming to life before
my eyes
cheers antoine your performance um
it's just not quite there yet okay i i
really need to see you make more of a
transformation okay like like nigel
here that dude's british
yeah antoine if i might jump in with a
bit of advice i don't think i need it no
no no no look hear him out
maybe you might want to try thinking of
something in the material that's similar
to something that's happened in your
real life
for me for instance i i like to think of
when me mom wanted me to attend prep
school in leeds to become a barrister
but i wanted to study the theater at
oxford thank god and so that was a
conundrum really for me i'm gonna stop
you right right there cause it's just
confusing me
right like i don't need that cause i am
from the streets
i was in a gang
they told me to kill my cousin
might be a bit spot-on no yeah that's a
bit spot-on do you have any stories that
involve your mom
what's up mom
oh dear scene five take three
okay
antoine remember
you're a gangster okay betrayal
the streets
okay nigel you're perfect antoine
transform and action
you sold me out son
now you're gonna get a blood up in your
head for it
you can't play me mother
i'm the mother
that plays [ __ ]
he's boring to watch
cut
that does not sound good
ed
i do not feel like you have found the
emotional core of this character man
this nobody is more real than me okay i
come from the streets and nobody's gonna
tell me what the streets is like nobody
you understand
that's a great speech i just wish that i
believed it you want to give it a shot
sure i'll have to go man
this i'm as real as you guess yes this
street is for real i'mma be in there man
you are
from the from the
from the earth from these streets from
the something to that defense no but i'm
so with you i'm with you when you say
that even when you're saying the wrong
words i just wish you could do that
okay that hurts but i don't feel that it
comes from the right emotional place for
the character all right here give it a
shot give me watch watch
oh that's that's great i
feel that in here and in here very
gracious in my heart try that again
i just
i don't i don't believe you i
i'm gonna go wash my hands oh okay
see
[Music]
buddy
um i'm sorry uh you that seat is
actually taken uh my girlfriend is in
the bathroom and she should be back any
second so you cannot sit there you don't
even recognize me do you no no i i don't
i don't know you we were in the human
centipede together i said i do not know
you three years ago we were kidnapped by
the crazy german scientist who
surgically connected us into a single
human digestive chain there were three
of us i was in the middle you were at
the end the other guy was up front your
mouth was sewn to my bottom okay yes i
remember and after years of therapy i
finally put that behind me probably
should have said you put it behind me if
you catch my drift i'm sorry i'm sorry
you already caught my drift i'm sorry
that's it it was right there in front of
me i'm sorry really i guess it was right
there in front of you that's it
i'm sorry
how are you doing
how are you is there something else i
can help you with um
hey
get ready
no don't call me that cup of squat no
ooh chili old habit's that hard
nice one oh no i can't eat it
why are you happy to see him come on man
you know we all shared the same
experience no he didn't he was in the
front nobody in his mouth that was true
do you ever stop eating ever only when
i'm okay well but me and you right me
and you what i mean we were in the same
boat nope you two were in the same boat
you both in someone's mouth i didn't get
in anyone's mouth
when do i get anybody's mouth huh when
do i get
in somebody's mouth stephen
i no
th these guys i can explain this i can
explain this
oh you're disgusted you know now you're
gonna leave oh yeah that's great oh yeah
once again i'm the [ __ ]
all right so that's just working easily
then okay good good good good good meet
you
awesome man okay we're gonna hurry up
wait another week i'm gonna get out
there
hey
sorry
y'all want to do some of that god drunk
[Music]
no who's this guy y'all never heard of a
girl draw
well well i've i've never heard of that
aka slayer
cuddy cuddy
double cutting
elmo
cat vag
long island brain slice
funt
funt font font i've heard of that it
takes all your greatest fears and
insecurities
and it gives them teeth and arms
and then it locks you in a room with
them
from which you cannot escape
[Music]
well that sounds terrible yeah i don't
want that those words are good you
realize the face of god is somewhere
inside your body
but you can't find it
and it hates you
um okay none of us are interested in
this drug thank you sir um nice meeting
you let's hear him out let's hear him
out it's a razor sharp crystal you tuck
under your eyelid
and then when your ocular cavity starts
bleeding it goes directly into your
brain
but like there's got to be a good part
yeah you've just described a life
wrecking physical addiction but if you'd
let him finish if he'd let him finish
he's gonna get to the euphoria i'm sure
just what you can't take anymore
you poop your mouth i'm sorry what you
poop in your mouth no
you poop out of your mouth i'm in dude
jeff come on man
hey guys if people are willing to go
through this the high must be amazing
buddy remember when you did mushrooms
and you cried for three hours this is
worse than that yeah oh yes
oh
how should i know
i don't do drugs
drugs are for losers
[Music]
there's no way that he can win no
no so anyway um what'd you think of the
season finale game of
no no no no no thrones no no i'm reading
the books oh i'm sorry sorry we saw the
first book and he read slow no
we could never talk about it
that's good okay
hey has anybody seen that new russell
crowe thriller because let me tell you
[Music]
sorry it's just we're going tomorrow and
i don't want to know a thing about it
doesn't want to know a thing gotcha okay
[Music]
okay
good
so yeah
what's the weather gonna be like this
sorry it's uh
we're having a barbecue this weekend and
i don't want to stress about the weather
no of course you don't we just yeah
[Music]
there's three being casual all this
stuff scooby doo bop
i'm so sorry babe i just i i hadn't
tasted him yet
i'm sorry i'm looking forward to
you know don't talk about the
ingredients i know yeah after surprise
for your mouth yeah i like that
oh uh
[Music]
if you got you know that commercial with
if you
[Laughter]
it's probably best yeah
yeah
um
no
cheesecake
got cheesecake
i mean oh yeah you know what yeah i'd
love some cheesecake let's do that yeah
yeah
yeah
i mean i've been watching my cholesterol
intake but what the hell right
well i'm gonna die someday anyway right
what honey wow are you kidding really
you just ruin it every time i see you at
home wait a second rude now how would
you not know that that was taking place
[Music]
hi hitler
my name is colonel hans mueller of the
sas
as you know
we were combing the area for shoes
but it has come to our attention that
two negroes have escaped and are hiding
out in this area as well
you wouldn't happen to
know anything about this now
would you
uh no
no negroes here
negroes ew
hell no
and um
what's your names leroy
hymer
leroy heimer is my last name and my
first name is very german and that is
because it is heinrich so my name is
heinrich leroyheimer
and i
am baron helmut
are you going to invite me in
yeah yeah yeah
please gentlemen sit down
now
as you know the negro not unlike the jew
can be a very tricky creature
oh that's fun
we have developed many tests to
determine if an individual is
in fact
an actual
negro
it's very scientific
like when we throw the beans up against
the homosexuals to see if the beans
explode
yeah uh
what kind of tests
it's interesting that you would ask me
that
would you mind
if i
removed your hat
so that i can measure your head
so negro head interestingly enough only
comes in the half sizes
it's one of the many interesting things
about some negro head
hmm everything seems seemed autumn
well
no negro heads here
i'll tell you what though
if a negro head came in here it would
find itself detached from its negro body
i'll tell you that right
am i right this is very very good but
there are so many exceptions to the rule
which is why it's so important that we
have a test
which is foolproof
more tests you know hunting the negroes
all day
you really build up an appetite you know
what i'm saying
can i interest you too
in some delicious beets
interesting the negro cannot resist the
bead it is drawn to it like flies to
chaser
well
gentlemen it appears i have wasted your
time
i'll be on my way
just one more thing
i'm curious as to how you feel
about
this catch toy
jiggly jiggly
nothing well that's embarrassing
i'm sorry for bothering you you two are
obviously not negroes
yeah of course we're not negros there's
a a no negro zone
thank you gentlemen ain't no time hello
eima
oh that's new
baron schnitzel nazi what's going on oh
hello
i'll wait for you here there we go all
right
by the way
are you by chance related to the ducel
law of schnitzel nazis yes i
am how's your aunt frida freida
she
is still
fat
i don't recall her being fat
but who looks like they did in college
anyway am i right not me not me not this
one
because i wasn't i mean
[Applause]
oh gutenberg
oh man that was close
we gotta get out of here man
he left the cat toy man
he left it
oh well
all right friends
the first fight of the evening will
feature one of my slaves versus one of
the slaves of my distinguished guest mr
jacob dixon
you know robert i hope you're as
gracious a loser as you are a host
all right
enough talk
[Music]
now
you devils fight to the death
[Music]
hey hey um
question
how do we get out of this thing alive um
it's it's really simple just let me
pretend to kill you
hmm
maybe it just makes more sense if i
pretend to kill you
yeah
i just
i want to make it believable so
that's what i was going for too
what the blazes is going on over there
and that endless clench tear him apart
okay uh
just die from this from this um
uh just you know what i just something
doesn't feel right so if i can just if i
just let me go with me
that was it that was it this feels much
more real so really what why um sorry
what do you mean why it's all right my
god
i'm getting frustrated now damn it kill
oh
no it's not a thing no i think i think
i'm okay i need to get i'm gonna get him
i got him let me get you though just let
me get you though no let me get another
one
it was my idea
stop fighting like sissies and kill each
other
all right let's just check this out all
right we'll back up
and uh you run at me real fast just do a
bunch of spins and kick some flourishes
and i'll just knock you out one punch
and then you're dead right no wait wait
what what i'm sorry so you can look cool
no thank you if someone doesn't die soon
i will kill you both thank
i'm not getting stronger from my
come
punches
listen listen let's be fair okay we both
slam into each other and we both die
fair
that's fair
one
this'll be good
two
oh you son of a [ __ ]
you were never gonna fall you didn't
even try to fall down you were never the
biggest thing is your you know don't let
that don't no don't hit you
hey everybody
war's over
slavery is abolished
sorry
we'll call it a draw done
good for you though huh
thank you let's go
well wait before you no no no no no no
no no hold on let's just just if just if
if i may who do you think would have won
the fight between the two of us
contextualized
they are stuck ahead of us every single
time
dick nannigans
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
it's amazing
[Music]
dick nannigans
it's a dialogue
absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
dignan against wow
[Music]
dignikins
dicknanigans
oh
gentlemen
exploded nut syndrome is a condition
indicated by the presence of exploded
nuts
which yours are
by the way i saw your show last night
amazing
all right listen up
sheriff's department's close by we'll be
safe there okay stay close
i'll get you out of here
okay we're still allowed here
all right keep it together yeah okay we
gotta make it to that sheriff station
oh my god
[Music]
we gotta get thrown just stay together
keep moving and don't get bit
go
are you getting this yeah what is up all
right let's go
[Music]
these are some racist [ __ ]
zombies why would you even lock the door
i mean the window's broken and oh
oh hell no no no no
oh
um
oh what is that they seriously wouldn't
let her eat us
hey guys
isn't this great
these racist zombies are leaving us
alone
come on we're having a party
the beer is here
[Applause]
[Music]
hey uncle ted oh jesus
sound content man oh keith
i got you didn't i yeah you got me man
you got me pretty good
oh so what's going on today oh just the
usual young buck just another day at the
laundromat yeah while people come in
they do their laundry we chatted up
about some of the topics of the day
that's just another day hanging at the
mat
i wonder what's going on in the barber
shop today
so it looks like they having fun over
there
[Music]
forget all that keith
come on we got our own assortment of
colorful characters right here in the
map
come on hey man you need any more
corners nope
[Music]
okay
okay
hilarious oh
hey there miss demetrius you need some
more quarters
oh she didn't hear me that's part of the
problem uncle ted
you know all that noise up in here from
the machines running and it's kind of
hot
[Music]
loud and hot
sounds like my old lady
[Music]
billy d williams is in there now he's
landlocalian he runs cloud city
[Music]
dammit keith
when i tell you we got it going on right
here at the map baby
uncle ted i got to tell you something
i got my own washer and dryer months ago
i just keep hanging out here cause i
didn't want you to feel bad
oh you didn't want me to feel bad
got your washer dryer all right
oh you're big-timing me now okay i see
how it is hey well your shirt ain't
clean your pants ain't clean
you can't get a good wash on one of them
home wash your dryer ted
i'm i'm going
i don't know wait wait wait wait wait
wait
let's have some fun let's have some fun
you can get in one of the laundry cars
and i could push it around no
[Music]
i'm out of here
wait
hold on and keep
don't work keep you do a little tap
dance and then you go
i'm your man
hey welcome to the barber shop young man
you're billy dee williams yeah yeah how
you doing i'm good thank you so much do
me a favor yeah could you let go of my
hands
oh thanks man all right
[Music]
good morning ladies and gentlemen we are
about to begin boarding south northern
airlines flight 34 to grand rapids
excuse me boarding group one i'm gonna
board a group one excuse me i'm in
boarding group one and
we would like to begin pre-boarding with
our first class passengers first class
passengers only please
next our business class passengers may
now board
okay now we would like to welcome our
regal alliance elite members
regal alliance elite members
okay now all passengers with children
anyone with small children you may board
now
okay we would like to continue boarding
with uniformed military personnel what
why get this is
thank you for your service thank you so
much for your service god bless you
thank you for your service
thank you for your service
all right people in wheelchairs
any priests nuns rabbis imams what why
do they get special treatment asalam
alaikum i've never
that's typical any old people in
wheelchairs with babies
[Music]
any old religious people with military
babies what's a military
thank you for your service
jason
schwartzman
anyone with a blue suitcase you may now
board finally no not you sir not me this
is a blue suitcase that's a blue
computer bag so you're not you're not
gonna let me on then
anyone who doesn't seem cranky
drunk people you will now be boarding
any drunk people
nope it's my bag
hello
oh hey christian
yeah
totally
well you have your favorites and i have
my favorites
okay
call you later
cow cow
morning group one
[Music]
[Music]
boarding group one over here
get a boarding group one
[Music]